an estimated 650 people live in southern
Springs in that small community it is
very difficult to find someone who
doesn't know one of these victims
mark Strassmann is that a sports field
in Sutherland Springs where people
gathered last night for a vigil mark
good morning
good morning this field is a memorial to
the unthinkable
there are 26 crosses here one for each
life taken in a moment of madness in
this tight-knit community everyone has
been touched by this and disbelief now
gives way to anguish more than a hundred
people gathered at this vigil in
Sutherland Springs Monday night many now
look for comfort to grow out of all this
shock and disbelief its case Schultz is
one of them this retired paramedic lives
a mile from First Baptist Church it's
gonna hit us in the gut when all of the
lights are gone that's when you know
it's gonna come home until Sunday few
places could feel farther from danger
than this small Texas town there's a
post office but no school and no police
department 88 year old Beulah Wilson is
the retired postmaster everybody knows
everyone when one hurts we all hurt her
family moved from San Antonio to
Sutherland Springs in 1954 to feel safe
it's just a very loving community we
have no violence it's a wonderful place
to live
Wilson's family has been attending First
Baptist Church on and off for more than
60 years she was not in church on Sunday
but many friends and neighbors were I
can't cry I just feel numb when do you
think it'll hit you when the three notes
something my children grandchildren here
yesterday but they told me said mom if
they don't come over here is too
emotional whenever I get to see them and
I start hugging them then I know it will
hit me that is real that it really did
happen and it it can happen anywhere
mrs. Wilson described First Baptist as
the anchor of this community as her
community struggles to heal she also
hopes its sense of safety and security
and peace of mind will also come back
Nora it will come back but it will take
time I mean is miss Wilson said you know
you it can happen anywhere and that's
what's so scary I think to so many
people that's what's so hard to
understand nor is certainly a place like
Sutherland Springs where they're just
doing the right thing small community
living their lives going to church it's
still in the end they find the strength
within themselves it's true that's also
true